Timothy Garnett is the technical
director in lead engineer at pan Java
where he's worked for eight years he's
been involved in all parts of their
product and in particular with ETL or
extract transform load aspects of their
data pipeline data ingest cleaning and
loading and he has an MS in computer
science from MIT thank you all right so
we're gonna be talking about global
trade global trade is big it's got big
ships it's got big networks it's got big
data or at least relatively big data and
it's got big money and it's also had a
big impact over the last say 30 years or
so global trade has been probably the
biggest driver of economic development
and poverty reduction at a global level
lifting directly and indirectly hundreds
of millions if not over a billion people
out of abject poverty into lower income
or middle income or even upper income
status but global trade is opaque and
opacity has costs makes it hard to
identify bad actors and it makes it hard
to reward good actors it leads to a host
of ills around counterfeiting diversion
labor abuse sanction evasion tax evasion
and a variety of other issues smuggling
and the like so what does Penn Chiba
intend to sort of do about this angeas
mission is to bring transparency to the
global trade industry to increase the
benefits to reduce the risks and to
deliver data-driven analysis and tools
and answers to the global trade
community Penn giba helps companies do
sourcing and leadless generation for
commerce they help people analyze and
vet potential partners they help people
manage their supply chains do market
analysis and the most part our customer
base consists of a lot of
importers exporters in the sourcing
world as well as logistics companies and
to some degree enforcement and
compliance organizations so something
that was in the news a couple days ago
so kind of brought about that but see
for 80s it's a non-profit I believe
based somewhere in this general area of
the country leverage Japan giba data
along with some other sources to develop
a list of Chinese companies that were
abetting the North Korean nuclear
program and in particular they
identified a very large company based in
northern China leading to the largest
enforcement action to date against a
company for supporting the North Korean
nuclear program spearheaded by both the
Chinese and American authorities so kind
of cool when we talk about trade data
what are we talking about for the most
part we're talking about shipment
records these can come in a variety of
granularities in the best case they're
telling us who sent a shipment who
received the shipment what was in the
shipment logistical details of how the
shipment traveled information
potentially about the volume or the
weight of the shipment in lesser cases
they may tell us only one side who sent
it or who received it or they may tell
us only sort of at a given company has
done an aggregate amount of a particular
cat product category or things like that
and this information is very spread out
it's a lot as collected by governments a
lot of it is is public information in
the US it's considered public record but
it's split up on me on a lot of
governments and a lot of agencies within
different governments and pengie of
attempts to combine that all together to
unlock the value present there so here's
an example of a sugar break it looks
like it doesn't look like this when it
comes to us in particular we have a lot
of challenges in sort of the ETL space
it's very I particularly done quite a
bit of that our company so if anyone
wants to talk more about the challenges
of that feel free to grab me during the
next break but just kinda summarize you
know we're dealing with a lot of issues
we're dealing with
incorrectly quoted CSV files and we're
dealing with files that could put
together by concatenating a lot of
fields and so you have a mixture of care
and coatings all within the same file we
have fixed with formats old COBOL
formats fix with formats where there's
inconsistent handling even within the
same file fix with in terms of bytes for
in terms of characters so the 10 10
bytes is it 10 characters sometimes and
it goes as far as the most Rube Goldberg
pipeline I can think of is that for one
of the reporting pathways carriers print
out a set of manifests of Records kind
of like this a subset of this of what's
on their vessel and then they it's
wherever mechanism they want internal
Excel whatever they just print it to PDF
whatever format they like then they
email it with a magic subject line that
has all the metadata encoded in it to
the government agency the government
agency takes that converts that into a
base64 XML blob and then since though my
F is SFTP site to us we take that
extract the PDFs and then process the
PDF doing a lot of form detection and
machine learning to to template eyes
these PDFs and pull the data out we talk
about the raw data how much we're
talking about currently it's about a
billion records shipment records from 14
different governments I like I said
before most of that is considered public
information available to FOIA as or
other mechanisms like that it's
currently supporting about a hundred
million dollar industry around trade
intelligence of which were a part and
out of this we pull you know eight to
ten million distinct companies
so with these company with these records
we're trying to extract out company
entities and then use these company
entities to build a larger picture of
what our trade and what the global trade
network looks like we use quite a
different quite a few different
techniques we're doing this generally
working with a name and an address of a
company but we're dealing with may
different governments so we're dealing
with you know the Chinese name of a
company as well as the English name of a
company as well as the Spanish name of a
company a lot of companies will use a
completely different name for trade
purposes than they use
we and the addresses can be all over the
place that could be just a country just
the city could be a very detail like
floor and street address depending on
the data set so we're trying to pull out
a lot of features out of this and feed
it into machine learning determine the
connections between these records and
then the clustering on top that
determines our sort of company entities
that feed into our trade network for
example an interesting feature is you
can look at the geolocation of the
address so we've found that there while
there are a lot of services out there to
geo locate addresses for you a lot of
them have a lot of trouble with
international addresses particularly if
they're messily or partial or incomplete
and so we actually do this as a
two-phase thing we use a machine
learning approach to first guess the
country or maybe more specific region of
the address and we feed those in as
hints to geocoding services now let's
let's get out you know for a given
example our it gets us you know a
location or maybe a circle of
uncertainty around a city or something
like that and that can feed in as a
feature to the machine learning so
here's an example company Under Armor
we've got over 700 variations of its
name and address some of them fairly
pathological and we we collapse all
these down into into one company or
generally trying to collapse first into
a specific location for a company and
then into a second higher tier of sort
of all locations of a company we make
both available through our platform
because different analyses generally are
focusing on one level or the other and
here's the kind of the end result it
looks like on our system it's a profile
of the company and you know this you
know ETL versus machine learning aspect
you lose a lot of trade offs like you
know how much time do you spend on the
ETL aspects of pulling out the data and
getting the data very clean there's how
much time do you spend on the machine
learning which may be able to paper over
a lot of those you know problems in the
initial extract layer and maybe a time
for another talk but that's an
interesting trade-off that we played
around with quite a bit here's another
part of the picture you can see this
company we have data from three
different cover
it's the US government the Colombian
government and the Mexican government
about their activity and Jason is going
to take it over from here and we're
gonna zoom out and look at this company
other companies in a sense of the
broader global trade network so Jason
thank you yeah so the sort of the the
fruit of the kind of large-scale ETL and
entity resolution that Tim described is
that we get a map of relationships
between different entities so in this is
what we have up here right now this is
actually showing you relationships
between Under Armor the company and the
port's that it does trade with each each
trace there is a shipping volume into
into several different different ports
but what I what I want to talk about for
the rest of the talk is relationships
between companies which has some you
know obvious use cases that will dig
into more so we can we can we can look
at the you know ones once you found
Under Armour the blue circle in this in
this description we can then look at its
suppliers its overseas suppliers in
orange so this is the the network of
companies supplying Under Armour you
know in the international trade space
and we have the ability to because the
underlying data that drives this graph
is so granular we have the ability to
slice it in many different ways to fit
different use cases so for example you
know the edges in the graph represent
flows of of shipments but you know
shipments of lots of different products
yeah so we have you since we also are
able to extract and classify the
products being shipped by these
companies to Under Armor you know we can
filter this graph to only look at
suppliers of polyester shirts or to only
look at suppliers in China of polyester
shirts if that's our interest but we can
walk out further we can look at the
broader somewhat broader network we can
look at you know Under Armor its
suppliers and other companies you know
that are also buying in from those same
supply
so I walked out to two degrees in the
network from the company we started with
from Under Armour and this starts to
answer you know be able to answer some
very interesting questions so you can
immediately see patterns that kind of
make sense here so you can see Under
Armour
so Under Armour and you can see other
you know their clothing retailers like
the gap you know Old Navy Old Navy in
the gap share several suppliers because
you know they're part of the same
corporate family but interestingly they
also share suppliers with Under Armour
and so this is the sort of questions you
can start answering if you're doing for
example a competitive analysis where I
want to know you know if I'm a
competitor of Under Armour you know for
example you know say I'm Patagonia and I
share the supplier right here with Under
Armour both sourcing from that same
company overseas I know I can use this
tool to see other suppliers that Under
Armour is also using that maybe I don't
know about yet so I could use the
competitive research of that sort also
you know you could use this kind of a
tool to to look at concentration of risk
in supply chains you can see if you know
a company is really exclusively relying
on on one supplier for you know a
critical part of its its inputs that
could be relevant we can take that same
network you can put it on a map as a
result of the sort of you know the
geocoding stuff that Tim described which
is its own kind of machine learning
stack it's after the same network I had
before just with the the companies you
know place placed at their location so
so using this you could see you know is
there a heavy geographical concentration
of of a company supply chain again
getting into the risk questions or I
could ask okay again it's more of a
competitive analysis or a strategic
thing I can ask are there regions of the
world where countries that my
competitors are exploiting that I should
you know also look into now we can keep
off you know for fun we can go out five
degrees so now it's it's the same thing
blue blue the Blues dots are all buyers
so there are there companies that are
sent importing goods on the shipping
records and the orange are suppliers so
they're exporting their Under Armor
there we see JCPenney which was one of
it's too hot neighbors that had some
overlapping suppliers with Under Armour
you know both both in apparel but you
know as you walk out you get broader and
broader slice of the industry you see
you know other retailers like IKEA you
see logistics companies that are there
carrying goods around for these people
and we can keep going we can look at the
entire network of international trade
and what I've done here to make that at
least fit manageable is actually rolled
it up to a network of communities so
I've applied community detection
algorithms to the entire graph of world
trade relationships and identified
clusters of companies that have
overlapping patterns of trade within
within the cluster as you know relative
with less trade between clusters so each
orange square in this in this graph is
such a community it's a network so this
is a network of networks and you can
look at the companies that make up each
of these communities and kind of see
that they fall into consistent industry
I'm just labeled a few of those for you
and so this is kind of cool I mean it's
it's as you may or may not expect it's
it's very complicated very densely
interconnected there's just trading
relationships going on you know between
between all all sectors here but there's
also patterns might expect like a heavy
heavy link between energy and chemical
you know links within within different
sectors of the retail space so you can
really trap the flows at scale and I
think that this kind of thing is sort of
neat you know you can get similar
representations of kind of macro trade
flows from other sources but where our
ability to do this is kind of unique is
that we're starting with the ground
level granular data and we're building
you know we're building these these
nodes these communities automatically
based on the patterns of relationships
that are revealed by that data so while
they do fall into recognizable
industries you know there are there are
some sort of a priori surprises so for
you
all this energy community you know it's
got all the big oil companies like Exxon
Mobil and Chevron but if you look into
it also has big cruise lines you know
like like Princess Cruises and that
makes sense when you step back and think
about it because big cruise lines are
huge consumers of energy so economically
you know there's a tight interlink there
which could be relevant for use cases so
I think this kind of you know bottom-up
analysis bottom-up you know driven data
driven ontology creation kind of could
complement other sort of a priori
categorizations of industries and of the
relationships between them okay so I
showed you a little bit about community
detection you know other standard
network analysis Texas can be brought to
bear you know on this problem domains so
centrality analysis if you want to know
who is a key component of a trade
network so for example if you were
looking at this network of North Korean
companies and Chinese trading companies
you know for some sort of enforcement
action you could figure out you know
who's kind of most important than that
you know alerting to network changes you
know we can we have all of these edges
in our networks are time dependent their
flows or shipments over time we can we
can detect anomalies I'll show you a
little bit more of the next few slides
of some examples of that but you might
imagine you you're maybe you're like a
small specialty foods importer you have
a great supplier of olive oil in Italy
you'd like to know if all of a sudden
you know Costco came in and started
buying olive oil for ham supplier we
could detect when that happens and send
an alert and all of this of course can
be done not just for relationship
between companies but also companies and
ports companies and geographic regions
you know products any kind of entity
that we're mining out of the shipping
records okay so that was the sort of
global zoom out macro view now I want to
go the other direction
you know zoom in look at networks around
individual company is kind of
interesting and specifically look at it
look at the impact
so of events over time so I'm gonna look
at things where there's an event that
impacts one company at one point in time
we can look at that in our data and see
how how it rippled out to other
companies in that network and a good you
know source of sort of public data for
these sort of point in time events that
have a strong bearing on trade is
sanctions and enforcement actions that
specifically that that that block you
know import since the into into a
country so for example there's a the US
Treasury office imposed sanctions on a
company in Belarus in 2011 the company
had ties to the government of Belarus
which were the reasons for the sanction
the result of that was that this company
was barred from exporting to the United
States and you know previous to the
sanctions this there was trade with the
United States you know we were able to
find this company in pangaea's database
and see who its
US buyers where it happens to be a
supplier of yarn so we can look at the
network around those companies here's a
sanctioned the sanction entity in
Belarus here is its u.s. importer it
happens to be there happened to just be
one one company in the u.s. that was
buying from this sanctioned company and
we can look at the broader network
around the u.s. importer and you know it
has another supplier with its own
extensive network you know not not very
interesting and a third supplier which
like the sanction one sort of
exclusively has a relationship with this
company in the US so that might be a
little bit more interesting so we can
look at what happened at the point of
time that the sanctions were imposed
here is the sanctioned entity shipments
to the u.s. importer stopped with the
sanctions but this additional exporter
in Russia happened to pick up its
exports right at the same time and it
had no trade to the US
all before that date and this also
happens to be shipments of the same
products as I mentioned we can filter
all of this by product to see this the
same type of yarn being traded by both
companies and we can look at it on the
map and find that they're actually
geographically you know close together
in the same world region so that that I
think is very interesting another
example comes from FDA inspection
warning letters so again this is public
information when the FDA conducted
inspection and finds violations they
issue a a warning letter to the affected
company and made you know potentially
take further action these letters are
publicly available on fda.gov and they
they list the name and address of the
company so I was able to pull these in
you know parse out the name and address
matched them to the companies in our
database through the same machine
learning driven into the matching that
we use to build the companies in the
first place
and find interesting examples of
companies that were affected by an FDA
action so in this case this was a
Chinese supplier of medical supplies the
the inspection revealed the some of
their products to be contaminated and it
was actually a serious enough violation
that they were they were they were
barred from their products into native
states after this inspection until until
the problems were resolved so what I'm
showing you here is the shipment volume
from the inspected company in China
to its top US importers so you so you
can see that you know when shortly after
the inspection you know that that that
those shipments dropped off but now it's
interesting to look at it stop it stop
those let's look at its top US buyer
okay so this is the same thing this is
imports by that top buyer from all of
its suppliers all of its overseas
suppliers so you know the distinction
company is one of you know one of the
traces here and what's interesting is
that apparently shipments to this buyer
just dropped off to zero from all of its
suppliers
after the after the inspection now I I
don't think that really is what happened
and it turns out that companies can
petition to have their names redacted
from shipping records and that's
generally what we see when that happens
is we just see no no data for that
company and so most likely that's what
happened in this case okay so I'm just
backing up then I think that you know
Tim and I describes how we're trying to
you know these are some examples of how
we can kind of bring some more
transparency some more insight into this
very opaque world of global trade you
know where the the things being shipped
around and big you know sealed
containers are very you know literally
opaque or the data that's generated from
them is is very you know in the raw form
it exists when you just get it from a
Freedom of Information Act request it's
very opaque very messy we're we're
cleaning that up at scale and you know
creating the groundwork for answering
important questions about trade thank
you